boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
what do you think is the meaning or the
purpose of life on top of a theorem you
can then build decentralized
applications on top you can issue your
own tokens journalism that's objective
and neutral and that serves the people
not the advertisers your physical assets
exposed to cybercrime a good question is
a big question how about do you think
we're alone in the cosmos definitely not
if we start sending people within a
thousand years tapas Atari the entrants
will push the box out the airlock and
the robot will grab the box so when the
iPhone came out everyone's creating apps
now everyone's creating Alexis skills or
Google actions ai is just a reflection
of of humanity first principles
reasoning the rethinking entire
industries rethinking entire
philosophies how much we have progressed
like in terms of absolute poverty so we
started a program where we take it into
[Music]
noticing the dirty streets if we were to
work with the people who are currently
unsheltered we'll teach you how to
become an entrepreneur the ethical
design is extremely important for me
crony capitalism and money involved in
special interest they have enough money
that they've been able to manipulate the
law to their own ends like and they've
been doing this as games ego and
consciousness and perhaps free will our
illusions you vote in order to show your
political allies that you're on their
side you give to charity in order to
convince the people around you that
you're an empathetic person with
hardware you can do anything that means
that people who have less than can be
blamed for their poverty universally
affected by the war on drugs the fact
that we are all connected on devices but
so disconnected
the real work where we are last day or
two where we are now was like
exponentially greater this brought the
data revolution into the NYPD
I think the immunotherapy and the immuno
engineering is the most complex set of
genetic engineering circuits that I've
seen so far our drug is targeted just
how much of ourselves is actually
microbial we picked flax because
actually has the highest stiffness to
weight of any of the different
technology in plants in fact it's like
aerospace grade strength we are feeding
these with organic molecules compounds
to enhance their immune system and make
them work more hours this idea of eating
well a basic right which is the
fundamental principle of our company you
look at at civilization in two hundred
or a thousand years Mediterranean
strategy for sustainable development
decide how we feel what we do today our
contribution we want to make no to death
no to interest a conscious leader to
transcendent include like to take what
was there before and grow appetite for
knowledge curiosity creativity are the
sources of all wealth tools for picking
instruments for flushing out songs when
you hear discussions about multiple
dimensions for me my hair stands up
developing all of these intelligences
all about understanding purpose we're
we're all connected we're all part of
the same like a different one community
a good question is a question that
allows for multiple layers of answer and
for for multiple nuanced ways of
thinking and might just be big enough
that the correct answer is I don't know
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world
I think
[Music]